Now let's see what the program's
view of memory is.
The program sees a huge
amount of memory, and
usually some contiguous regions of this
memory are actually used by the program.
And there is an enormous region in the
middle, between the heap and the stack,
that the program will never access
unless the heap grows that way.
But the heap is usually small relative
to how much space we have here,
because it's a huge,
huge amount of memory.
So what happens is the program
thinks it has a lot of memory, but
in reality most of that memory,
it will never access.
And this is what we call virtual memory.
So the program virtually
has a lot of memory, but
in practice there isn't
that much memory.
Another program has its
own virtual memory.
Let's say it's a small program.
So it's using less memory,
and less for the stack, so
it has more memory here
that it's not really using.
But the idea that the program
has about this memory
is that it can always use more.
So this is the virtual memory of one
program, this is the virtual memory
of another program,
they might be running at the same time.
Let's say this is our physical memory.
We need to figue out
what happens when this
program generates an address that
should access this memory location.
How do we find where in
here do we actually go?
And if this program accesses a memory
location with the same address,
how do we figure out where does it go?
It might go to a different
place in the physical memory.
For example, when these programs
have nothing to do with each other.
It might go to the same place
in the physical memory.
For example,
if these programs are sharing data.
In fact, data sharing among
programs is not constrained so
that you have to put the data
in the same virtual address.
You could easily allocate this here,
and then let this program share it,
but as far as this program
is concerned it's here.
It still needs to map
to the same location.
So how do we reconcile these
different possibilities?